monsieur jean marie vanlerenberghe au
nom de la commission des affaires
sociales a déposé une motion distribuée
sur le numéro un pendant à opposer la
question préalable au texte en
discussion et la parole est à madame
catherine de roche présidente de la
commission pour la motion et pour dix
minutes d'un madame la présidente madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur
général
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues nous parvenons au terme
d'un parcours singulier pour le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2021
les principaux articles de ce texte les
tableaux d'équilibrer la trajectoire
pluriannuelle et l'objectif national de
dépenses d'assurance maladie ont été
rectifiés à plusieurs reprises dans
chacune des chambres en première lecture
puis à nouveau à l'assemblée nationale
en nouvelle lecture ce texte est inédit
par l'ampleur des déficits et
l'incertitude qui s'attache à la
révolution ses déficits abyssaux la
probabilité qu'il se creuse encore
davantage le sénat les a acceptées il a
soutenu les efforts déployés par le
gouvernement pour tenter d'éviter que
notre économie mise à mal par les
restrictions liées à la crise sanitaire
ne sombre ces efforts se traduisent par
une plongée vertigineuse de finances
publiques qui n'était qu'à peine
convalescente
devant ce constat le sénat portait de
messages principaux le premier c'est
qu'il faut réaffirmer et préserver
l'objectif le moment venu du
redressement de la trajectoire de nos
comptes sociaux
il tient une raison très simple les
dépenses sociales sont des dépenses de
transfert et si elle dérape durablement
c'est le système tout entier qui risque
l'effondrement
ce n'est pas notre choix nous tenons un
modèle social solidaire et pour le
préserver il faut le financer
ce premier message s'est traduit par un
amendement au rapport de l'année ce but
qui décrit la trajectoire pour les cinq
années à venir et ne porte aucune trace
de redressement après 2022
il s'est également traduit par un
amendement sur la question des retraites
notre système de retraite a fait l'objet
de nombreuses réformes
paramétrique ce qualificatif ne rien
piger relatif s'agissant d'un risque qui
se pilotent bien par trois paramètres le
niveau des cotisations celui des
pensions et la durée pendant laquelle
elles sont servis avant que la crise
sanitaire n'interrompe le processus
le sénat devait bien examiner un projet
de réforme des retraites transmis par
l'assemblée nationale après recours aux
49 3 une conférence des financeurs de ré
examiner les moyens de parvenir à
l'équilibré à l'horizon 2025 pour
l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme
systémique en agissant sans doute sur
certains paramètres
le sénat a voulu relancer ce processus
car nous savons que la réforme est
nécessaire qu'elle ne sera plus que
jamais demain et qu'elle sera d'autant
plus douloureuse qu'elle aura trop tardé
pour autant et cela m'a même au second
message porté par notre institution
s'il faut impérativement réformer il
faut le faire dans un cadre clair et
pour de bonnes raisons
en d'autres termes s'il faut réformer
les retraites demain
ce n'est pas parce que l'assurance
maladie a dû payer les masques de santé
publique france s'il faut augmenter la
contribution au remboursement de la
dette sociale
ce n'est pas parce que la cadette se
financent sur les marchés pour permettre
aux hôpitaux d'investir c'est pour ces
raisons que celles à refuser les
modalités de reprise d'une partie de la
dette des hôpitaux
ce ne sont pas des raisons théoriques
elles ont une portée pratique et très
politique
nous sommes finalement favorable à la
règle du chacun chez soi
mantra du précédent gouvernement pour
justifier une ponction sur les excédents
la sécurité sociale qui ne se sont
malheureusement jamais matérialisée elle
suppose de revenir aux fondamentaux des
assurances sociales en clarifiant les
financements en fonction des risques
couverts accidents du travail chômage et
retraite se financent par des
cotisations qui ont une contrepartie en
prestation c'est le sens de la loi veil
les allégements sans compensation ne
produisent que des déficits
en dépit des critiques adressées au
pilotage de sécurité sociale il n'a pas
perdu de vue l'objectif
à la différence du budget de l'état qui
est celui de l' équilibre
nous ne devons pas le perdre de vue non
plus et nous pensons qu'il serait
illusoire voire dangereux de prétend
pouvoir à terme d'en dispenser ayant
constaté un désaccord sur ces points
avec le gouvernement et l'assemblée
nationale la commission des affaires
sociales a considéré avoir épuisé le
dialogue institutionnel sur le projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2021 alors qu'il y avait
des points supplémentaires d'accord
possibles lors de la nouvelle lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
est ce nous le regrettons c'est pourquoi
la commission vous demande de bien
vouloir adopter la motion tendant à
opposer la question préalable je vous
remercie
merci je n'ai pas été saisi de demandes
de parole contre la motion je demande
donc madame la ministre
l'avis du gouvernement alors sans grande
surprise évidemment mon avis sera
défavorable
je voulais en tout cas ce stade déjà
vous remercie infiniment pour la qualité
des échanges que nous avons eus pendant
cette discussion parlementaire
oui moi j'ai la correction de vous
laisser parler madame quand vous parlez
ça c'est une habitude que vous devriez
avoir chacun parce que je pense que
c'est lorsque vous étiez à ma place
d'ailleurs vous le faisiez régulièrement
je voudrais vous dire que j'ai bien noté
évidemment les désaccords qui demeurent
entre d'abord les deux chambres et puis
aussi avec le gouvernement et nous
aurons loisirs je pense au cours de
l'année de discuter sur d'autres sujets
qui me sont chers j'aurais vraiment
plaisir à vous retrouver au fil de ces
discussions donc voilà donc mon avis est
défavorable mais en tout cas merci
davance merci pour les explications de
vote j'ai une demande de parole de
madame cohen oui merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre
cette question préalable au niveau du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes nous la trouvons justifié
justifier je crois que ça a été
soulignée dans dans l'est dans la
discussion générale par les arguments
qui ont été développés nous mêmes au
niveau de mon groupe nous avons déposé
une question préalable des là
le début de la première lecture parce
que nous ne nous faisons pas d'illusions
sur la qualité de l'écouté des débats
qui pouvait y avoir au niveau du sénat
par rapport à la majorité présidentielle
et au gouvernement
mais je veux souligner ici que nous
n'allons nous n'allons pas voter en
faveur de la question préalable nous
allons nous abstenir
pour une raison très simple et que mes
chers collègues de la majorité de droite
vous allez comprendre
nous ne sommes pas du même avis que vous
quant au retour à l'équilibré financier
de la branche vieillesse
nous en avons discuté lors de la
première lecture c'est à dire que vous
voulez reculer encore l'âge de la
retraite
nous nous disons qu'il y à d'autres
choix à faire et que dans une période en
plus de pandémie avec un accroissement
du chômage c'est pas cette fois là cette
voie là qui rockent qu'il faut prendre
donc comme sa figure dans la question
préalable
nous n'allons pas la voter mais j'attire
votre attention madame la ministre une
fois de plus sur le fait que ce plfss ne
prend pas du tout en compte le fait que
nous sommes face à une crise
structurelle de notre système de santé
et que les différentes mesures les
différents articles qui sont votées dans
ce plfss ne vont rien régler du tout et
j'attire votre attention notamment sur
les déserts médicaux déserts médicaux
tout le monde s'en plaint tout le monde
le vit dans sa commune dans son
territoire
et qu'est ce que vous avez trouvé de
mieux à faire dans ce plfss c'est de
faire une course d'obstacles pour les
centres de santé qui sont une des
solutions pas la solution il y en a
d'autres mais vous allez vous avez vous
avez mis noir sur blanc que finalement
les centres de santé sur des zones
surdotées encore faut-il les définir
d'ailleurs et bien vont devoir avoir un
agrément de l' agence régionale de santé
c'est à dire que vous multipliez les
courses d'obstacles
alors qu'aujourd'hui on est face à un
manque criant de professionnels de santé
et que la volonté de la majorité des
professionnels c'est de travailler en
salariat donc ce sont des raisons que
vous ne voulez pas entendre et qu'on ne
peut même pas débattre avec le ministre
de la santé puisque ils jouent aux
abonnés
absent donc pour toutes ces raisons là
je la tire à nouveau votre attention et
nous nous abstenons sur la question
préalable merci madame la présidente
merci madame pons et montez vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre nous sommes donc amenés à
nous prononcer sur cette question
préalable
il s'agit de la quatrième motion sur ce
texte en autant de débats pour les deux
assemblées de notre parlement
fait rare à la hauteur du mépris de la
majorité présidentielle vis-à-vis du
débat démocratique et du travail
parlementaire que l'examen du texte à
marche forcée il tombe sur le fond qu'à
travers la méthode ainsi madame la
ministre votre majorité à l'assemblée
s'est appliqué à un minutieux travail de
démantèlement des amendements approuvés
par le sénat au terme d'une semaine de
débats
d'où qu'ils viennent sur les bancs de la
haute assemblée
trahissant par là un flagrant dédain de
la part de cette même majorité quand
content parce qu'il ne vient pas d'elle
il s'agit là d'un jusqu'au boutisme
aveugle alors même que depuis le début
des crises que traverse notre pays le
président la république multiplie les
appels à l'unité nationale
alors qu'en même temps votre majorité
bafoue le rôle du parlement par ailleurs
après plusieurs ajustements du
gouvernement au fil de l'eau c'est
désormais systématiquement dans des
conditions et des délais d'examen
resserré que l'exercice législatif nous
est imposé c'est ainsi sans le temps de
recul nécessaire entre la fin d'examen
par votre collègue par nos collègues
députés mardi dans la nuit puis
l'arrivée en commission sociale hier
matin que nous débutons cette nouvelle
lecture
évidemment pour celles et ceux qui
considèrent le parlement comme une
simple proche une simple chambre
d'enregistrement
rien de surprenant autant vous dire que
c'est ne pas notre conception du travail
parlementaire
vous l'aurez compris ulcéré par un fonds
dogmatique et par les procédés
péremptoire de l'exécutif et de sa
majorité
les sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoires
s'abstiendront pour la même raison qui
vient d'être donné
compte tenu de notre désaccord sur la
soi-disant nécessité de corriger les
déséquilibres structurels de la branche
vieillesse
ce qui fait partie de la motion je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à mme la présidente
laurence rossignol
merci madame la présidente heures
quelques mots pour dire que notre groupe
ausy s'abstiendra sur cette motion sur
cette question préalable
nous nous abstiendrons elle sera adoptée
c'est une bonne chose qu'est l'essence
de cette abstention c'est que à la fois
nous voulons envoyer un message au
gouvernement qui est celui que les
différents collègues qui sont intervenus
à un moment où vous voyez c'est à dire
que de nombreux amendement avait été
adopté au sénat
ces amendements avaient une grande porte
et je pense par exemple à celui présenté
par un autre groupe sur le non recours
au droit qui aurait pu considérablement
améliorer la vie des plus défavorisés
ces amendements n'ont pas été examinées
retenu la commission mixte paritaire a
échoué très rapidement et une fois de
plus la capacité par législative du
sénat n'est pas prise en compte par le
gouvernement
donc c'est une raison suffisante pour
qu'effectivement nous ne refusons pas
l'exercice de l'examen du texte pour
autant nous sommes pas non plus d'accord
avec le texte tel qu'il avait été adopté
par le sénat et en particulier avec
l'amendement que nos collègues de la
majorité avaient déposé et fait adopter
sur le recul de l'âge de la retraite et
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons nous abstenir
c'est un double message à la fois
l'égard du gouvernement et à l'égard de
nos collègues avec lesquels nous
travaillons bien mais avec lesquels nous
avons aussi des différences que nous
devons toujours chercher à résoudre mais
ne pas nier enfin madame la ministre ne
vous offusquez pas que des
parlementaires puissent s'exclamer
pendant vos propos c'est le jeu du
parlement ça se passe comme ça il suffit
de lire le journal officiel
et vous même vous avez été une députée
qui était pas totalement muette dans
l'hémicycle donc je comprends bien que
la place où vous êtes c'est beaucoup
moins amusant parce que vous ne pouvez
pas interrompre et parlementaires mais
franchement ça fait partie du débat
parlementaire aussi qu'on puisse lancer
une petite phrase temps en temps et tout
à l'heure je vous disais que si vous
vous satisfait du débat avec le sénat
nous mêmes nous satisfaisons pas du
débat que le gouvernement a mené avec le
sénat merci la parole est à monsieur
chassang
dunham et miss mes chers collègues
malgré la dégradation du budget de la
sécurité sociale dans un contexte
extrêmement difficile
je pense que le gouvernement a bien fait
d'augmenter les salaires des soignants
alors on n'en parle pas mais je pense
que les personnes qui travaillent qui
ont travaillé difficilement qui ont été
dans les ehpad
après 6,7 cette augmentation il est
sûrement nécessaire dans l'avenir comme
ça a été dit on même président de la
commission et d'autres de revenir de
s'inquiéter sur les retraites parce que
il faut maintenir leur niveau et ça
c'est quelque chose dont il faudra
s'inquiéter rapidement nous avons
considéré e
je prends la parole parce que en fait
notre abstention est différente
nous avons considéré qu'une partie des
13 milliard de reprise de
l'investissement des hôpitaux et bien
été pour une partie je dis pas la
totalité parce que dans ces 13 milliards
il ya sûrement du gros oeuvre
mais je pense qu'une partie est due à ce
qu' il y avait un financement de l'ondam
sous dotées je rappelle que quand même
entre 2012 et 2017 l'ondam n'a pas
augmenté tout à fait 2 % si vous voulez
alors que le les dépenses de la sécurité
sociale était de 7% donc on a des
hôpitaux qui était en déficit et qui a
été obligée d'emprunter même pour
renouveler du matériel le courant donc
je souhaite bien sûr aussi madame la
ministre que dans le plan santé et bien
la cinquième branche de l'assurance
maladie puissent être financés puisque
on a un déficit de l'emploi au niveau eu
des ehpad et pour prendre en charge nos
aînés il faut absolument qu'on augmente
très rapidement le nombre de deux
personnes
dans les ehpad donc notre abstention et
que nous recrutons dans cette période
difficile il n'y ait pas pu y avoir
d'entente pour ce préfet cesse entre les
deux assemblées
parce que pour redresser la sécurité
sociale les biens je pense qu'il faudra
de l'unité mais aussi des entreprises
compétitives qui vont cotiser pour
redresser la sécurité sociale donc c'est
dans cet esprit que nous obtiendrons
merci la parole est à monsieur lévriers
si madame la présidente quelques mots je
n'ai pas redire ce que j'ai dit dans la
discussion générale
nous voterons contre nous l'avons dit
pour beaucoup de raisons mais la
principale est finalement le respect du
bicamérisme j'en suis désolé mais quand
on parle de débats de ce côté là en
pensant plutôt invectives que débat en
s'en prenant à une ministre qui remercie
je suis un peu surprise pour moi ce
n'est pas le débat le vrai débat c'est
la controverse c'est l'explication c'est
le travail ait refusé une deuxième
lecture d'appel fss c'est m en face à
face des très grandes mesures jeu
l'argentin n'est que quelques-unes qui
sont l'augmentation de l'andam le ségur
l'augmentation des salaires la cinquième
branche le congé paternité et en face on
met des excuses et mois des mesures qui
ne sont pas applicables comme les
retraites qui arrivent au dernier moment
et on sait très bien que le gouvernement
que qui a travaillé dessus depuis
plusieurs années avait une très très
grande réforme et qui a été arrêté parce
que justement nous sommes en pandémie et
qu'il faut reprendre le temps de
travailler avec les français je regrette
qu'aujourd'hui le sénat ne veuille pas
débattre et montre aux français le peu
d'intérêt du débat démocratique je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à madame dit autant
merci madame la présidente juste
quelques mots mois pour compléter mon
propos nous avions quatre minutes c'est
un peu court donc rappeler
qu'effectivement nous allons voter
contre cette motion préalable sur une
question de principe puisque le groupe
rds s'oppose à toutes les questions
préalables privilégiant le débat c'est
la première chose il y avait un point
bloquant pour la grande majorité notre
groupe et l introduction des
propositions retraite dans le texte
malgré le fait je
je tiens à leur dire que cette réforme
des retraites est absolument aujourd'hui
indispensable donc nous n'étions pas
contre sur le fond mais c'est plutôt
l'inscription dans le texte qui nous
dérangeait et enfin je voudrais dire ce
n'est pas un blanc seing pour le
gouvernement loin de là parce que moi je
vais clairement rejoindre mes collègues
ce g et nous avons le sentiment que le
sénat n'est quand même largement pas
écouté l'absence du ministre de la santé
sur l'ensemble des débats était quelque
chose quand même de surprenant voire de
choquant et on a quand même l'impression
qu'à chaque fois que nous faisons des
propositions soient s'est repris ça doit
être repris par le gouvernement soit
c'est un peu balises d'un revers de main
donc je pense que voilà ce vote compte
n'est pas un blanc-seing en vis-à-vis du
gouvernement loin de là mais maintenir
que ce plfss est quand même un plfss de
crise qui relève quand même certains
enjeux merci je vais consulter le sénat
sur la motion tendant à opposer la
question préalable
je rappelle que l'adoption de cette
motion entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion
donc en application de l'article 59 du
règlement jusqu'au un public ordinaire
et de droit
le scrutin est ouvert
[Musique]